so the next thing to talk about is uh
stacked imbalances now most people are
familiar with stack and balances okay
and so this is like nothing new to a lot
of people it's when three or more buying
imbalances are stacked neatly on top of
each other
or when three or more selling imbalances
are stacked neatly on top of each other
but they have to be
stacked neatly on top of each other
okay so for example here okay
this is a stacked sound imbalance right
you got one two three they're stacked
nice and neat on top of each other okay
i don't think there was any buying and
balances on this
10 years that's what a stacked
selling imbalance looks like and now
there's different ways you can use it
right you can draw out
on the software when you have a stack
buying a balance or stack selling a
balance you can draw out this
zone okay you got two choices
um there's it here you can do
fixed or until tested okay
fixed is if you have it fixed you have
this
size here you can draw it out five you
can draw it out ten
okay but if you have until tested it
will show up
there until the market comes back there
then it'll stop drawing once the market
pulls back to that level of that stacked
imbalance
okay now you can adjust the level of the
imbalances
and it's all right in here imbalance
trigger in percent
so if you don't want to use 400 say you
want to use 300 percent
three to one you change it to 300 okay
but 400
is fine for most people um i know some
people that use
300 i know people that use 10 to 1 000.
now
depending on the market you know say
you're trading nasdaq or something right
three is nothing in the nasdaq three
levels right one two three
maybe you wanna make it five you know
look for levels for stacked imbalances
where there's five
levels of imbalances stacked on each
other but for most people you know the
the starting point is three
and four hundred right three levels
at four to one okay
now crude oil
okay what day is this this yesterday
now just show you these
imbalances so i have the imbalances on
stacked imbalances what do i have on
here check it
okay until tested four hundred
and three okay
but just show you what it looks like
right so until tested here right this is
64 87 to 64
89 all right i don't think it came back
there but
yeah it didn't um
crude oil i think we're in for a sticker
shock this summer
um with crude oil but let's go back to
the day before okay so you can see these
levels
right here what was that level 60 40
okay so here right you have this level
here
60 45 right
so 60 40 to 60 45 right you got this
nice stacked imbalance in here
boom boom boom okay market goes higher
spending all this time well above that
level now obviously it came back
during this number traded through you
know you
did a hold you know obviously you got
that knee jerk reaction but
generally when you're trading you know
using these things as tested
until tested right you're basically
going to be drawing out these lines
right you want to know
what how the market is going to react
when you get back to it because
there are times
where the market comes back to these
levels
and the market holds beautifully okay
right this one just went right through
what was that other level here
there's this 40 oh this one here 97
97 to 93.
if i came back here that day
no but you're looking for these levels
to be tested again
all right here's the s ps
you know here tested that level
yesterday um
okay these are sweeps which i'll get to
in a minute but um
yeah you can see these ones these
imbalances you know
there's an imbalance is running from way
way back there
right it came back now obviously we
spent a lot of time above
came back down towards that level you
know and it's testing it right
it sure violated 32 just down to what
28 and a half okay considering that you
know we
we sold off from 72
all the way down you know a 40-point
move you know don't always expect it to
stop right at that level
right okay you just you could work a bit
in here
you know in the micros 32 right you put
in
a four-point stop five-point stop all
right because you know if it
bounces off that you know it moves just
retraces back
half of that 40-point move
you know that's 20 points you're risking
five points okay
you know that that's what is that four
to one five to one
okay so that's stacked imbalances so the
next thing i'll talk about is
multiple imbalances all right and this
is something that not a lot of traders
pay attention to
okay multiple imbalances are important
and very important in my opinion
in my mind and
multiple imbalances okay
when you're looking at a bar right there
could be more than
three imbalances either buying or
selling and they're not
but they're not stacked on top of each
other does that mean that those
imbalances are not
important no right they're still
important
right yeah we like to see things stack
neatly in in order but
you know the market's messy at times
right you get these imbalances that are
spread out
that doesn't mean that well they're not
stacked on each other these
imbalances are are useless right that's
that's not true
okay so in here under val volume
imbalances in here you can see multiple
imbalance bar outline
it's set to violet and it's going to
look for a three again you could look
you know you could use five if you're
trading something like
um nasdaq or something you know or
mnq or even dao something a bit volatile
dax but three is good enough for most
people now again it's
the most the imbalances are related to
this setting here so if you're going to
use
you know if you're using 300 as your
imbalance threshold whatever you're
using for multiple imbalances as well as
stacked and balances is set to 300 we
don't have it separated it's connected
there
okay and really what you're looking for
is imbalances ideally
you're not the point is not to trade
every single bar with multiple
imbalances right take it in context with
what's happening in the market
right are you at a swing high or are you
at a swing low
let me just
remove those lines so for example
yesterday right yesterday was
um you know kind of a hectic day in the
markets okay so
look at this right we're selling off
here
we sort of get to the swing low right we
just sold off you know from the 90s
all the way down into the 60s a 30-point
move okay
now you're starting to see some bullish
activity right obviously the delta's
positive it's 1969.
the max delta is 1970. so you close
within one
contract of your max delta that's
bullish the min delta
is zero okay there was no
at no point where the aggressive
seller's in control of this bar
obviously you got the zero prints
but look at this it's got a box around
it it's got that violet box it's telling
you that there
are multiple buying and balances in the
bar
okay you see there's one two three four
five six
imbalances right so imagine you just
sold off 30 points you got a zero print
you got
nice positive delta the max min delta
relationship
is is bullish you got multiple
imbalances
all right all you got to wait for is
just you know the next mark the bar just
next bar to start showing you some
bullish activity it does it starts
trading higher you know you get long up
in here
72 72 and a half 73 even
you know it pulls back a little bit 69
okay
but look well look what happens right
rallies from 72
what all the way up to back up to the
90s right
get up to the 90s what do you see you
see a bar with multiple selling
imbalances
right then another bar with multiple
selling imbalances as you get right up
towards the swing high you start coming
off you got
price exhaustion right you got that
little single print up here it's a
little hard to see
right up here one lot right you got a
bearish ratio i'll talk about ratios
later
and the market sells off um
crude oil
again um whoops i take off these lines
here
again i'm not looking to trade every
single
bar with multiple imbalances you know
where's it going what do you think
is going to be effective you know when
you're making new highs you want to see
bars with multiple buying balances
that's normal right you want to see that
aggressive selling
but if we you know get to um you know a
swing high
or you know a swing low and i start
seeing
multiple silent imbalances coming in at
a swing high or or multiple
buying about let me get to the day
session here um multiple selling
imbalances
you know at a swing low you know that
that's where i'm ready to
you know take action right here we got a
little move up
that's not multiple um you know here you
get this high
right yeah you know i would take this
trade
but then you know obviously you got to
watch what's happening in the order flow
right it starts to move down okay but it
just stops goes sideways on you
fine the trade didn't work out you're
not going to sit here and get short here
hold it for one two three four five six
seven bars
before you get stopped out it's not
working immediately
that's your time to get out you don't
have to sit there and wait till the
market stops you out
um you know
again you know i find it you know
trading in context
and now we're coming up on the close of
the day that was the fourth
let's go back to friday more recent
you know your higher the day you got
your divergence two bars later you got
your
exhaustion in here you've got one two
three four
imbalances right as the market sold off
you know look at 10 years
again obviously you got multiple
imbalances in there i don't think you're
going to see many in the 10 years
honestly
you might but unless there's like a
number that came out
but if you see it you know in a market
like the 10 years you know here's one
this was a stacked imbalance
um you know but if you look at a market
like bonds
even you know here's this stacked
balance let's take a look at
at bonds you know honestly trading 10
years it takes a certain mindset
you know you've got to uh be patient
because it moves very slow at times
and it just trades lots of volume but
if you're looking at you know other
markets so this is the bonds
um you know
if you change it you know this is a four
range chart and trying to get
a four range chart you've got one two
three four five price levels right so
seeing you know three imbalances on a
four range chart sometimes can be a
stretch so if you're using
something like a four range chart or
five range chart
maybe you want to set it you know on
certain markets you can i'll show you
right you can adjust it to a smaller
level
right this is set to two so it's going
to show me
bars that have two right here's two
selling imbalances
there's two here obviously this is you
know two
two but again you know it depends on the
market that you're trading um i think i
got gold up here
gold let's take a look here
you know as this market's moving up you
want to see imbalances right as the
market
comes into a swing low right you want to
see buying imbalances
but again you know it's a tool you could
use to
form your own trading strategy around
right it's it's not about just taking
every single
selling stat multiple selling and
balances right
like here or um you know or here
take them in context of the market right
because really that's what you want to
do
now the next part of imbalances
is the inverse imbalance okay and this
is something that's not going to show up
necessarily in a lot of bars now an
inverse imbalance occurs
when there are trapped traders
in the market um and
let's see you can see more on certain
markets like
you know gold or nasdaq
all right m and q you'll marcus had a
bit more volatile you'll tend to see it
make sure i got it turned on here
okay so inverse and balance is in here
under the volume
imbalance errors right here so it's
going to be blue
for bullish or red now it's going to if
you have a stacked imbalance it's going
to draw it over the color because it's
in my mind it's a it's a stronger
it's a stronger tool okay
basically but again it's it's not
something that's going to necessarily
appear
in all markets every day
and it appears it's really designed for
the more
volatile markets because those are the
markets that tend to
move around a lot quicker right and
you're gonna see people getting
stuck in positions more i'm not
ninjatrader
but
again there's not many examples in the
gold all right i'll tell you what i'm
going to do
i will open up m q
or just enqueue
and i'm not going to use a minute chart
let's use a 30 second chart um let's
give it a second to come up here
let's see if there's any in the e-minis
here
but really this is
a tool like right here okay this is an
inverse imbalance
all right when you see that right it's
red you want to be
short right if it's red right obviously
this is when the number came out what
happened you got that knee-jerk reaction
you got all these
people trapped up here right this is
inverse imbalance it's a stacked buying
imbalance
in a red bar and you got to be wondering
why is there a stack buying imbalance in
a red bar
well it's because people the number came
out
people thought hey you know i'm gonna be
smart i'm gonna jump in front you know
they started buying it right that's how
you got that inverse imbalance there
um i don't think there was anything in
the night before
but let's just take a look here
again you know i didn't
create slides for all the stuff because
i just want to show you in the market
what it looks like right because rather
than
oh you know pick this slide pick that
slide
you know that that's nice but you know
at the end of the day
you know you got to trade as the market
is unfolding before you here's
an inverse imbalance right you got that
red it's a buying a balance right but
it's showing you as
red because what's happened is you know
market was going up up
up up and then it just started hanging
around here people got aggressive right
people got interested in taking this
market higher
it left that imbalance in there that
inverse imbalance and what happened
the bottom dropped off right these guys
realized they were stuck
and sold off right the market came back
up where to come back up to that area
that they were
and then the market sold off let's see
if i could find a
a buy in here buy would be
blue color again in a market like
e-minis during the day session you're
really not going to get a lot
just because it trades so much volume
now look at this okay so
i don't know
i just want to go back to this level
here right this 3822
okay one this was an imbalance from
way way way way way way way back here
right here okay
look at that imbalance here 38
22 right that stacked imbalance again
you know this is why
you talk about these zones being drawn
out right 38 22
trades all the way down you know
obviously
i mean sold off you know way down into
the 3700s
then we came back right
came back
look at that came right up to it that
was the high of the day that was at
7 um 40 right
this was on the fourth which is what
thursday trade one tick into it you got
the divergence
and the market um started selling off a
bit from there
but anyway that's that but let me go
look at
nasdaq for an inverse imbalance of
by um
again that's why if you're drawing out
those zones um
you know until tested you know it's
always amazing to see sometimes they
just literally right come back to
that particular level and this is a
30-second nasdaq chart
um which moves pretty fast
but you know what i can do i could
adjust it a little bit but
i want to find a good example of a buy
for you honestly
the way the market has been the last
couple of days you know trying to buy
things is
is kind of hard so here's a bearish
involved
bearish inverse imbalance right there i
really want to find a bullish one
yeah could be that it's set too tight if
sometimes you know like i said other
people sometimes they use
different levels four to one is sort of
the industry standard but if you used
um i'll turn off
stacked imbalance for now uh you know
you could use
two to one you know you could use
three hundred percent three to one right
so again i'm just showing you this for
example purposes yeah the whole point of
using order flows to get you to think
about
what matters to you and your analysis in
the market
so i'm going to use a box size of two
or sorry two imbalances i think it's
going to be two
and it's going to be set to three to one
okay so there's obviously going to be
more um
opportunities for it to come up on so
just bear with it here for a second
let's take a look at crude
this is the crude markets uh uh
let's go back through the crude real
quick
again if you're using the four to one
you're not going to get a lot but if you
want i like to look at inverse
imbalances
when they occur um
yes even in crude because you know
markets that trade a lot of volume
you're not going to get a lot of
inverse imbalances unless there's like a
number that came out
that caused the inverse imbalance to
happen
that's still coming up takes a while
because nasdaq's just got a
ton of data it's got to load now
again you know you see me flipping
through charts right and
here's another long term stacked
imbalance right where to do it came
right up to that level and then dropped
20 ticks
but you see i'm just right now i really
want to focus on these
inverse imbalances let's give it a
second here
so you know here was a buy one here
again it's set to this time it's set to
two imbalances at 300 to one
let me expand it here so you can see
right in here right so it's a weaker
signal
because the imbalance levels threshold
is set lower
and it's just looking for two right
really what you want is
nice strong imbalances
again here's one here but again
you got to have the order flow telling
you which way to go
in this case this is a bullish one
because it's coming over here but this
bar
right it's hard to read the order flow
in this bar because that's the problem
with
nasdaq it just covers so much ground
very quick
all right this is the imbalance all
right
but the next bar opens up below it
that's not the type of trade you want to
take right
you want to be trading up to here right
finally you break up here and go higher
but
is this one obviously is when the cash
opened
you know you don't want to be getting
short like here's one here here's one
here
you want to be getting short below this
this level not above it
all right just as you want to be getting
long above this level
not below it that's what you're doing
when you're dealing with um
imbalances is you want to be going in
the direction of the imbalance you know
you want to be
you don't want to be fighting that
imbalance right
you know here right there was your
imbalance right then the market started
going higher this is your inverse
imbalance
it's blue it's bullish right so you want
to be trading above it not below it
again another blue one right you want to
be trading above it
you don't want to be getting long below
a bullish inverse imbalance you want to
be trading
above it um anymore
again this is the night session
again here right you got your bullish
one here but we opened up
below it right that's not the trade you
want to take eventually it did trade
higher
and you got a selling one you know which
sort of canceled each other out
bullish one yeah it was above it then
once it starts coming back towards it
obviously that's not the trade you want
it's a bearish one but we're trading
above it you don't want to be getting
short from above the imbalance are you
going to be getting short from below
the selling imbalance right here
boom now again you know nasdaq is a
different beast altogether
it's not for every every trader um
i don't recommend new traders trade
nasdaq basically
it moves too fast for them and then they
they get frustrated
now unfinished business now this is an
old thing unfinished business has been
around for a long time in order flow and
it's really better for
normal market conditions now we're not
in normal market conditions you know
markets got a lot of volatility
it's really for range days you know days
that you're in a trading range where
you're looking for
price to come back to that level now
basically an unfinished business it
shows the areas where the buying is
selling don't complete in the sense of a
bar forming as it should
so meaning there should be a closed
auction at the top or
of the bar or the bottom or the bottom
of a bar
okay and you don't always get those okay
now
again under current market conditions
i don't think it's um useful anymore
because we're just too volatile in these
markets but
again you know people they go on the
internet and they read about unfinished
business and they think it's
you know a great thing but honestly
it's meant for certain market conditions
okay and i've talked to
traders that have been using order flows
you know since the you know
are using other trading software
watching
you know the footprint chart you know
going back to the the early 2000s and
you know they're telling me when they
first developed
i don't say develop but you know when
they first sort of noticed what
unfinished business was
the market conditions were completely
different and they would look for the
market to come back to those levels
um you know relatively soon like within
30 minutes to an hour now people want to
carry these levels for
a long time but i'll just show you what
it looks like here
on the chart again i don't use them um
they're there because you know obviously
when we developed the software
it was more it was an effective way to
to see things but honestly the way this
market is now
it's just it's there's just too much
volatility going on in the market to
really
in my opinion the way i
i've always used um unfinished business
now again you know
just because i use unfinished business
in one way doesn't mean that that's the
only way you could use it
you know people everyone's got their own
ways of using unfinished business
not not their own ways but you know they
may have
wrapped it up with um you know
another another form of market analysis
but here i'll just add it on a couple of
charts here so you can just sort of see
now there's two settings actually
with it when you enable it and
i can't spell here you unfinished
business there's you can see
detect unfinished business and draw
broken levels
if you have just detect unfinished
business it's going to find the most
recent ones so at the and then it's
going to
undraw the ones that were there earlier
but if you have detect
broken levels it'll show all the levels
okay because if you have
um just detect unfinished business it's
just going to show you
where it is currently so if you're at
the end of the day
right it's just going to it it'll just
show you the most recent lines
okay but again i have it showing
all the unfinished business here and you
can see you know the top of this bar
that's your unfinished business now
again you know the really the way you
really want to be applying it
the way it was sort of meant to be
applied was
when you go up to a fresh level not
necessarily every time you say you have
it
right that it's just because you have it
in a bar um
doesn't necessarily mean anything right
it's got to come at you know a swing
high or swing low
but you know it's it's one of those
things that you know people sort of read
about and they get enamored with it
um and they think that you know that
that's oh that's
that's this hidden way of reading the
market so like here right the unfinished
business
the market came back to because you
could have unfinished business in a bar
and the next bar could come in usually
would just come in and finish it
what you want is you want the space all
right you want space
between the bars for the market to come
back to you don't want to have here
unfinished business now it's just it
gets completed in the next bar
right here right which is often what
happens it completes it in the next bar
here
right what you want is you want to have
space that's why i say you know look for
it at
swing highs and swing lows right here
you got unfinished business
trading below that unfinished business
came back up finished that business
and then came back down now the way it
was explained to me years ago
by traders that were using it for a long
time
under different market conditions right
those were the days
when we'd have you know a 15 point range
in the e-minis for the whole day
right so they would you know there was
less volatility in the market
so they would be looking for you know
the unfinished business and then the
market to come back to within a half
hour
you know maybe an hour max but they're
not
looking to hold these levels for all day
you know they're just looking for the
market come in complete that auction
and then continue its move right so you
want to have space between
now if you draw the
unfinished business here just go
under unfinished business
all right if you take out the the broken
levels
because these levels are all broken
right
it's gonna be a lot cleaner but it's
just gonna show you
the most recent one so you gotta
you gotta scroll to you know the the end
of your chart
to find it okay so like for example here
all these lines
would not be there it will just show you
the most recent ones obviously this
market's closed so i don't think it's
going to show you anything
but let's see here if the e-mini's come
back up real quick
but you know it's kind of pointless to
have every single broken level
drawn on your chart but if you're
watching the market during the day
constantly
you know monitoring it then yeah you
know
maybe you want want to use it but again
you know for me
i just don't i don't use it anymore
okay come on it's taken a while just so
much data
plus today i think my kids are
using the internet it was a little bit
slow
but again when you're looking at
unfinished business right don't
try to extrapolate it out for hours and
hours right you're looking for the
market to come back to that level
and complete it and you'll usually
complete that level pretty quick
right it'll it'll usually happen
in the next bar or two right so that's
why when you're looking at
you know like almost every bar here has
come in in the next bar
and and completed it
honestly looking at it
you know maybe if i was on a five minute
chart it would look different
okay so you can see here e-mini is right
it's not showing anything because
there's no
um current unfinished business that's
sort of
unresolved right
but here let's pull up the five-minute
chart on the bonds
we're just showing everything
but yeah okay here's one here right from
32 right you got this unfinished
business right down here
it's red line okay
obviously it's there still there you'd
have to
well it's not going to show it only
shows it on the actual chart so you'd
have to draw that line so as
as it drops off the chart
all right so you can see it is showing
here right but if i go there it's gone
they're just going to show it on the
most recent chart activity
so you can see here right this is the
five minute chart
in the bonds um yeah so you don't really
see
it generally unfinished business gets
resolved pretty quick
all right there's one here o2
you know we came down in there
oh three so anyway again you know it's
up to you if you want to use unfinished
business
or not market sweep detector now this is
a new one that's in the order flows
trader software
okay and what it does is shows areas
where big traders
sweep through several price levels in
one trade
and again you're probably not going to
want to use it
on a market like nasdaq because it's
volume
related okay so nasdaq doesn't trade a
lot of volume at price levels you know
it's a lot of ones and twos go through
at a price level
so let me turn off the unfinished
business of this chart
first okay so here moving
along market sweep detector is turned on
it's set to three
it's going to look for three sweep
levels and the sweep threshold is going
to be set
to 10. now just so you don't get
confused i'm going to turn
off the all this volume and balance
stacked imbalance and inverse and
balance
because the colors are
green and red let me just clean up this
chart here while we're waiting for that
chart to come up
turn off this volume imbalance
turn off the unfinished business and
i'll turn this off
and i get
now under here on the sweep
i'll set it to a slightly higher number
since the 25 it's the bonds
so i don't know bonds
it's a little harder to see sweeps in
there because there's just so much
volume that goes through
um gold
see like well all right so like this is
nasdaq okay
and you can see here right using the
sweep market sweep function isn't going
to be very effective
because there's a lot of areas where it
just skips through price levels right
the market is you know 27 bit at 28
or 27 bit at 27 and a half offer
right and just trade jumps through these
levels a lot of zeros in there
so you know you're probably not it's not
going to be effective
in a illiquid market like nasdaq
okay so here's the bonds so like here's
a sweep right right on that number
mark you know big traders came and swept
right through the market obviously the
market
continued down here's a sweep right here
right boom boom boom
as the market continued to sell off
right so the market is just hanging
around here big trader came in
sell it you know sell it down you know
it's trading 10
and he sweeps it down to 07. right you
can even see
turned it off right here right the 309.
so he sold what was
bid here at nine the bid at eight the
bid at seven and turned it off at seven
so he's probably sold about 500
contracts you'll just sell me 500 here
down to 07. boom
filled you know here's a sweep here's a
bullish sweep
right here
there's another bullish sweep and bear
sweep there
um but really you want to be paying
attention to it more
during the course of the trading day and
at night because at night you got less
volume so it's easier to
sort of sweep through the market okay so
here's the uh e-minis
let's see if there's any sweeping
activity
here so sweep here here's a bullish
sweep but we couldn't continue
right we closed down below it again
imagine you want to be getting short
below the bearish sweep and
long above the bullish sweep but you
want to be getting short immediately
or long immediately you don't say well
there was a sweep here
and now you're going to get long five
minutes later no you know you're looking
for that action to happen
quick and this trading a sweep right you
want to
take advantage of it quick right you're
going to scalp it basically
you're not going to buy and hold for an
hour or two hours
all right you you see it you're going to
get involved
all right that's the whole point of
trading a sweep is
you see some big activity in the market
and you gotta you gotta participate
right you want the market to be going
in your favor
you know sweep here right sweep sweep
right as the market's moving higher the
bearer sweep didn't do anything you've
seen some bullish sweeps in there
and again you know it depends on the
market that you're trading again i'm
just showing you a one-minute chart
because
that's where a lot of people sort of
come into the trading
environment and is looking at a
one-minute chart okay
this is a nice sweep here this is a
bullish sweep but it couldn't even
continue
right it didn't even go any higher
couldn't even go above the sweep right
you want the
the continuation now sometimes sweeps
are caused by stops
stops get triggered in the market and
you know it just runs through it fills
the order okay
so that's you know it does pick up these
stops that's why sometimes you see stops
or sweeps at highs of bars or
lows of red bars highs of green bars or
lows of
red bars ideally you know you want the
sweep to happen
ideally i don't say all the time but in
the middle of a bar
generally i find it going to be more
effective because like down here
you know it could just trigger a stop
right in here whereas if you're selling
in here
right you broke the low here big seller
came in
moved it down right in the middle of
this bar
it moves higher
market weakness detector
it's another new feature of the order
flow trader software and it measures
you know the weakness in the market and
it's designed
to show it to you anytime
weakness is detected but again you know
you got to trade it in context of the
market
okay you want to be selling weakness
when after markets rallied right and you
want to be buying weakness
after the market is sold off right you
don't want to
um you know for example here
i'll show you a couple so
the market weakness shows up here where
are we
i'll take off this well i'll leave that
on
but market weakness enable market
weakness
set to sequence length of three but it's
going to be blue or orange right so
let's
if it's a bullish market weakness now i
know that's kind of confusing bullish
market weakness what is that
well it's just telling you that as the
move is going down
the weekend the move is is weakening
okay and it's
going to turn bullish or bearish as the
market's been moving up but the
aggressive buying has been weakening
right so it's going to be orange i'm
looking for blue or orange
okay so for example here right here's
the orange now we had just sold off
right
okay well you really want to be getting
short after the market just
had a nice sharp move down now here's
another bearish
market weakness now the market had
recovered a bit come back
up it's testing a level and you're
seeing the buying
now right
okay that's why it's time to get bearish
right whereas here
right we're already selling off so
you're already expecting bearish
you know not bearish but especially
weakening buying coming in right
yeah okay well we're selling off already
so
it's going to be more effective to be
buying it
or sorry to be selling it after a pop
higher
right in this case we're testing this
recent swing high and you're seeing the
weakness come in right
and the market obviously goes down and
then again you know the next bar
it's got to start breaking down right if
you're getting short
right you got no follow-through in the
next bar here technically this is
bullish
right based on the order flow that's
happening in here
but we can't even close up near the high
of the bar we close a little bit off
then obviously the next bar can't even
take it out so again it's not about just
buying and selling every time you see it
let the market tell you that yeah we
still have that continuing order flow
because what's happening in the market
right
is when you trade
right you have your idea of what the
market's doing
but you also have to have all the other
traders out there
also believing in what you're saying
right in your sort of analysis right
they sort of have to sort of
come to the same conclusion but if they
don't
then you're not going to get that
follow-through order flow right and the
last thing you want
right you wouldn't want to buy then
elsa and something bearish comes out you
know or
you know people are still bearish in
their thoughts and then the market sells
off right you want the market
to start moving in that direction based
on whatever right it doesn't have to
be necessarily based on your analysis
but people have to have
a bullish stance for the market you know
to continue back up
um let's see here where i got
a crude chart here um
okay all right you know
going up we pull back start moving back
up bullish
right bullish market weakness bullish
market weakness
um sold off again do you want to be
getting short after you just sold off or
after you just rally up a bit
and you see the weakness come in here
this orange right this orange and this
orange
right you don't want to be just taking
them willy-nilly blindly
right but even in this case the bar the
next bar doesn't even
take out the low of this bar right it's
just it's
well up inside whereas over here
you know the next bar starts trading
lower those are the trades you want to
take
right just not oh you know i got a
orange arrow i got to get short
oh yes you got to think right that's
what being a trader is about is is
putting the pieces
of the puzzle together right you want to
analyze what's happening in the market
right if it doesn't happen then you know
no no trade
right you know here's one you know it
started
you know i don't say it was coming off
but you know the high of the day is
right here you got a bullish signal
you know it just went up and it's you
know unfortunately this one would have
stopped you out right
then it made that move you know that's
how it goes sometimes
right there's just still a little bit of
selling pressure left in this market
to move it down
you know look at bonds it was anything
in the bonds
go to the friday session here
you know here this is actually the
fourth you know right before the big
sell-off here right we're just sort of
hanging around going sideways you know
we pop up a little bit and then wham we
get slammed down
now people say well let's you know move
down well yeah
i like to look at this more as a move
sideways based on the value area which
i'll get to
in a bit but
you know again try and take it in
context here right your low of the day
is right here
right and you see the weakness at the
low of the day the selling weakness
right coming in at the low of the day
what do you think the market's going to
go down well it could then you see the
next bar also exhibiting the weakness
right
and it goes up all right a little bit
um you know there's one it didn't go
anywhere
uh see i think that was it
again buying into the high of the day
honestly i'd rather be looking for these
blue arrows at lowe's of the day or at
swing lows not
not the high of the day so anyway the
next thing i'll talk about is the value
area um
and you know this was a big thing that i
wanted to put in the software for many
years
and honestly i couldn't decide how i
wanted to show up in there
and i just decided to put in
the value area basically just to
highlight it in the bar
okay rather than drawing a little
profile in the bar
and showing the value area high the
value area low um
yeah that's been done by other people
and you know that that's all well and
good
you know then people start get fixated
on sort of
um you know i'll call it formations of
the order flow or
rather of the profile i just find it's a
little cleaner
showing it as you know
here right so this area between in this
green bar right
the value area is between 37 30 and a
three-quarters and 37 33 and
three-quarters that's why it's gray here
now you can adjust it okay
in here so say you don't want to use
seventy percent right most people use
seventy percent because that's the
one standard deviation but you can
you'll have people say well it's really
sixty eight point whatever but
you know 70 is fine you could adjust it
to
50 say you want to look for you know
depending on how you're trading you want
to look for areas where the volume is
really
compact right you can change it to 50
percent um
i wouldn't really go above 70 because
otherwise you're going to cover the
whole bar eventually
and the next thing i'll talk about after
that is the eva right i have it enabled
here okay
and you probably wondered why on some
charts you see
are some bars you see blue
and red those are the evas those would
be a bearish eva and a bullish eva
now value area rise is
generally the point of control will
appear in
the value area right the point of
control is the level in the bar with the
most volume
once in a while it may actually appear
outside of the value area
and you know i've done some testing on
it
you know is that important or something
because you know why would the point of
control appear outside the value area
that must mean something right
honestly so far i haven't really found
anything um conclusive
really to be interested about um
on it but you know when you're looking
at value right the value areas
of a bar is
not just in context of the bar right oh
yeah you see the value area low here
evaluate high
is you start to use it
in context of the previous bar right
just as you would if you're using volume
profile
and losing the value area of the day
right you could use it on a bar by bar
context and it's important you know and
talk about it here so for example on
this bar right here
okay we open up outside of the previous
value area
we trade back in we reject it we trade
higher
okay that's important right now
obviously
this red bar we open in the previous
bars value area
then we trade away from it okay that's
fine now
there's bars where um
let me just find it here for you
where we open outside of the previous
bars value area
and we come all the way through the
value area
right um
again you know these things don't always
appear as often as you'd like to see
them but you know they're important
things and that's why we have the
um you know things like the value area
on the chart
right so when they do appear you know
how to take advantage of it
so here right we open up right the value
area low of this red bar
is here right 29. we open up at 28
and a half 28 and three quarters trade
all the way up through the other side of
the value area and we keep
going right now that's a bit like an
engulfing pattern
but we just continue in that direction
right so you always want to be looking
for
things like that and there's all sorts
of different ways to use the value area
and you know in our weekly sessions i
talk about these things you know things
you can be looking for
in the value area right there's gaps in
value
value area gaps what that means and i'll
just tell you right now usually when i
see two gaps in a row there's one gap
here's two gaps
we tend to come back in and try to close
both of them
it's not like gap one gap two and just
go higher
um you know if you see three gaps really
you're going to be looking for a
pullback
um at some point right gap gap pull back
um you know it's not a gap there but
you know that that's what you'd be
looking for right that's the analysis
that you want to start
getting into now
the ebas right there's bearish ones and
bullish ones the bullish ones are going
to be blue
the bearish ones are going to be red and
again you want to be trading it
in context of the market right whether
you're looking at the bonds right
bullish eva right here right market went
up um
bullish eva right here after a move down
here's
a bearish eba right here after a move up
you've seen bearish signs right and
again it's based on the volume
right because it's looking at the the
volume of the
of the bar of what's traded right we're
at the high of the day two bars later
bearish
value area right that's why it's red
right the market sold off
um
you know bullish one but couldn't even
go higher than expire just hung in there
and traded lower um you know that's
bonds right let's take a look at
something like crude
bearish eva right right as the market
dropped down about
20 cents um again i'm just you know
here's one but we couldn't go lower in
the next bar or two
right that's not what you want to take
here's one went lower than
two bars later and again from 30 you
know a small move
nothing to get too excited about here's
one right here look at this move
you know move from 20 what is that 23
down to 73
right here's a bullish eva right finally
popped higher
got higher not the next bar but two bars
later
and it moved from you know what 70
up to 90 right this was a bearish one
but we didn't go
any lower here um here's another bullish
one
right there's a bearish one right up
here okay
so you know that's the whole concept of
the expanded
value areas right it analyzes the value
areas and highlights to you the value